[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le 7-8
week-end sur tv 78 actualité idées de
sorties pour bien terminer la semaine
dans les yvelines voici le programme de
ce 20 mai le nouveau gouvernement
d'elisabeth borne a été dévoilée ce
vendredi après midi parmi les personnes
nommées yaël brawn peavey députée
sortante de la 5e circonscription des
yvelines qui devient ministre des outre
mer est la présidente de l'université
paris saclay sylvie retailleau elle a
été choisie pour être ministre de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche un relais de la flamme
olympique à vélo l'action et de passage
ce samedi dans les yvelines et est à
l'initiative du collectif vélos ile de
france l'objectif réclamer la
réalisation d'un réseau cyclable de
desserte des sites et des jo de paris
2024 et puis comme tous les vendredis
nos idées de sorties pour samedi et
dimanche dans les yvelines ce sera dans
la deuxième partie de cette émission
avec un retour celui de bixente mayence
insisté ban après un repos bien mérité
bonjour bixente bonsoir grégory chaque
vendredi vous nous donnez votre
sélection des idées de sorties dans les
yvelines pour pour samedi et dimanche
qu'elle est menu du jour un week-end de
fête ce dans les yvelines on va
commencer par à la fête à saint jean de
luz d'effets de base à saint-jean-de-luz
à saint-germain-en-laye les fêtes de
saint jean de luz ensuite fait de la
nature du côté de plaisir et bien sûr
dès ce soir vendredi la fête des voisins
et ce sera tout à l'heure bien sûr dans
le sais tu ce week-end
mais d'abord l'actualité la composition
du nouveau gouvernement d'elisabeth
borne est enfin révélée a été révélé en
fin d'après midi quatre semaines après
la réélection des manuels macron une
yvelinoise fait partie de ce remaniement
il ya les brawn peavey 51 ans a été
nommé ministre d outre-mer elle remplace
sébastien lecornu qui était en poste
depuis 2000 20 avocate ancienne membre
du ps devenu en 2010 est député de la 5e
circonscription des yvelines ian brown
piégé est devenue une membre important
de la majorité présidentielle elle est
la présidente de la commission des lois
à l'assemblée nationale première fois
dans notre histoire politique avec un
député devient président de cette
commission dès son premier mandat elle a
été aussi élu en 2020 conseillère
municipale du vésinet y est le monde
pouvait que nous avons réussi à joindre
par téléphone juste après l annonce de
sa nomination voici sa réaction
à part une réaction de joie
j'ai le parcours de quelques uns de la
société civile qui s'est engagé en
politique avec tout son coeur sans
l'énergie
le parcours que j'ai il récompensé
aujourd'hui et puis surtout une immense
responsabilité
parce que les autres
sont grands et donc avoir en charge
cette ce domaine de l'action de l'état
c'est quelque chose d'exaltant de
passionnant et et en même temps une très
grande responsabilité je sais que nos
compatriotes attendent beaucoup donc je
suis
conscient de la charge qui lui même si
elle devient ce soir ministre d
outre-mer ya le brune peavey reste bien
en course pour les élections
législatives au programme les 12 et 19
juin prochain elle est candidate à sa
réélection dans la 5e circonscription
des yvelines l'agenda des prochains
jours risquent donc d'être chargé on
écoute à nouveau il ya le groupe va
continuer à l'être mais je vais
continuer ma campagne comme précédemment
faisant beaucoup de terrain en
rencontrant beaucoup de monde hier
j'étais encore en réunion publique à
sartrouville donc je vais je vais
continuer ma campagne sur les chapeaux
de roue et bien évidemment
fonction le plus rapide
et un peu plus de 18 heures passées
nouvelle heure où nous prenons l antenne
pour cette émission nous ne savons pas
encore l'heure officielle de cette
passation de pouvoir pour la nouvelle
ministre des outre-mer autre nomination
comme ministre elle n'est pas yvelinoise
mais la présidente de l'université paris
saclay qui regroupe notamment
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines sylvie retailleau 57 ans
devient ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche poste
occupé depuis 2010 cette part frédéric
vidal physicienne de formation elle a
fait toute sa carrière dans
l'enseignement elle est diplômée de
l'école normale supérieure de cachan
agrégé des sciences physiques est
titulaire d'un doctorat en sciences elle
avait été nommée présidente de
l'université paris saclay lors de la
création de l'établissement début 2020
pas de réaction encore à vous proposer
mais nous reviendrons sur ces deux
nominations dans le journal de la
rédaction de tv 78 de lundi prochain qui
sera largement consacré à ces deux
entrées ya lebron privé et donc sylvie
retailleau qui deviennent ministres et
qui participeront à leur premier conseil
des ministres ce sera lundi le
gouvernement qui est donc connu à trois
semaines du premier tour des élections
législatives le premier tour est fixé au
12 juin prochain bixente mayence insisté
ban est toujours avec moi en plateau
puisque jusqu'au scrutin tv 60,18 vous
aide à y voir plus clair dans les enjeux
dans chacune des 12 circonscription des
yvelines avec vous bixente focus
celui-là sur la 6e circonscription la
cinq places 6e circonscription des
yvelines on parlait de la cinquième il
ya un instant mais là c'est bien la
sixième on peut commencer peut-être par
la situer exactement dans la sixième
circonscription des yvelines située au
nord du département comprend les villes
de saint germain et le pecq hr pour que
marie marie chambourcy et aigre non ce
fut la circonscription de michel
péricard le père de l'actuel premier
magistrat de saint germain en laye puis
pendant trois mandats de son suppléant
est maire de chambourcy pierre morange
une circonscription donc ancré à droite
ce qui n'empêchera pas la défaite de
pierre morange en 2010 est balayé par la
vague macro nist et par la candidate en
marche natalia poussière la plus directe
qui est candidate à sa propre succession
oui et rappelons qu'elle est ingénieur
qu'elle a travaillé dans le groupe
thales puis chez airbus et en cinq ans
les choses ont changé elle pourra
bénéficier d'un soutien qui pèse lourd
celui d' arnaud péricard actuel maire de
saint germain en laye qui a rejoint
emmanuel macron et le mouvement horizon
d'edouard philippe il tient célèbre
avocat dans la course oui l air a en
effet choisi un nouveau venu en
politique l'avocat thibault de montbrial
il a plaidé dans des affaires célèbres
c'est lui par exemple qui représentait
les intérêts de nafissatou diallo en
france dans l'affairé strauss kahn il
est intervenu dans la sphère renault
pour défendre des salariés accusés à
tort d'espionnage industriel il a plaidé
dans l' affaire clearstream il est aussi
connu pour avoir défendu de nombreux
policiers il est d'ailleurs favorable à
l'élargissement de la notion de légitime
défense très proche de valérie pécresse
il l'a soutenu lors de la campagne
présidentielle prenant notamment à son
compte les mesures qu'elle défende est
en matière de sécurité et qui sont les
autres candidats la candidate de la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
solidaire nuque c'est une enseignante
melinda et melinda sauge et de la france
en soumises autre parti le rassemblement
national qui est relativement faible
dans cette circonscription notamment
certaines villes comme saint germain en
laye marine le pen est arrivée derrière
valérie pécresse et eric zemmour
toutefois le rain sera défendu par une
femme maria macedo desousa enfin
d'autres candidats sont déclarés pour
pour ne pas les énumérer cécile
perraudin pour la lutte ouvrière
stéphane boucher pour reconquête
jean-luc sauzée suffisait pour le parti
animalistes julian very lac pour le
parti pirate et stéphane richard
nouvelle union écologique et sociale les
ege les élections législatives seraient
des ronds se dérouleront donc et 12 et
19 juin prochains voilà pour les enjeux
sur cette sixième circonscription des
yvelines si vous nous rejoignez on
parlait de ces enjeux et et tout au long
de cette campagne jusqu'au premier tour
mais mains de ce premier tour des
élections législatives je vous disais tv
70,2 va vous aider à y voir plus clair
autour des enjeux de ce scrutin un
retour à présent sur les autres faits
marquants de la semaine dans les
yvelines quels sont les actualités à
retenir celle yaga tsongo vous résume le
tout en 78 secondes
[Musique]
elle a choisi la ville des mureaux pour
son premier déplacement la première
ministre elisabeth borgne s'est rendu au
pôle molière elle a rencontré des
associations qui agissent en faveur de
l'égalité des chances et de
l'émancipation des femmes depuis
plusieurs jours l'eau manque aux
cultures yvelinoise une période de
sécheresse qui commence à inquiéter les
agriculteurs conséquence une perte de
rendement pour certaines exploitations
ou un manque de nourriture pour les
élevages la ville de ben se lance à la
recherche d'un éco garde communale une
première dans les yvelines son rôle
sensibiliser et valoriser les espaces
naturels de la ville il pourra également
verbaliser les incivilités de jeunes
entrepreneurs proposent un nouveau
concept nommé la tournée une livraison
quotidienne dans le nord yvelines de
boissons avec des bouteilles continuer
le but réduire les déchets et remettre
la consigne au goût du jour
première phase de restauration terminée
pour le château de dampierre en yvelines
elle a été marquée par la dépose du
filet de chantier et puis enfin la
finale du championnat de france unss de
handball se déroulait au gymnase mont
boron à versailles victoire du lycée
saint joseph de toulouse 24 à 23 contre
le lycée saint cricq de pau le sport
scolaire à l'honneur aussi avec les
gymnases yade qui ont réuni 500 jeunes à
rambouillet
[Musique]
un
relais de la flamme olympique à vélo de
passage dans les yvelines samedi 21 mai
cet événement est organisé par le
collectif vélos ile de france et vise à
réclamer la réalisation d'un réseau
cyclable de desserte des sites
olympiques en vue des jo de paris 2024
interview express avec jeunes brûlent
chargée de campagne au collectif vélos
ile de france
[Musique]
l'action flamme olympique c'est un
relais à vélo de fausses flamme
olympique du coup entre les associations
du collectif des loups ile de france
pour rappeler l'urgence à agir pour
faire des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques cyclables donc on
interpelle paris 2024 l'état et les
collectivités à mettre en place au plus
vite un vrai plan d'action porte pour
djo cycab
[Musique]
l'objectif c'est de rappeler que les
jeux sont une formidable opportunité
pour développer le vélo en ile de france
l'enjeu est que les spectateurs puissent
accéder au site à vélo de manière
sécurisée c'est un enjeu d'efficacité et
d'image d'efficacité pour que les
spectateurs puissent utiliser le vélo
s'ils le souhaitent les transports en
commun qu'ils seront bien remplies et
d'image pour montrer que l'ile-de-france
qu'un objectif neutralité carbone en
2050 et une régions cyclables dans un
moment où tous les projecteurs seront
braqués sur elle les yvelines c'est le
deuxième département qui accueille le
plus de sites olympiques on en réseau
cyclable pendant ce mois qui est souvent
interrompues et les jeux sont un
accélérateur pour résorber ces coupures
[Musique]
les deux relais partiront de la
courneuve en seine-saint-denis et
d'elancourt dans les yvelines ils se
rejoindront à paris au pont d'iéna et
pour les urines on va passer dans devant
plusieurs sites olympiques donc la
colline de l'encours de pelles autour de
saint quentin en yvelines et château de
versailles notamment avant de continuer
vers la ville puis sèvres et paris
[Musique]
votre rubrique à présent dans le 7-8
week-end légal chez king pour décrypter
l'actualité avec le collectif des
surligneurs aujourd'hui zoom sur la
polémique autour de l'autorisation du
burqini dans les piscines de grenoble
c'est avec raphaël mata duvignau
le préfet de l'isère annonce vouloir
engager un déféré laïcité procédure
créée par la loi dit de séparatisme 2021
pour demander au tribunal administratif
la suspension de la délibération du
conseil municipal qui autorise de fait
le port de burki dans les piscines
municipales jugeant ainsi cette mesure
contraire au principe de laïcité or la
laïcité ne s'applique pas de la même
manière sur les personnes en effet s'il
est interdit aux agents publics de
porter une marque d'appartenance
religieuse trop voyantes les usagers eux
jouissent d'une liberté totale sauf
exceptions prévues par la loi pourvu que
cela ne porte pas atteinte au bon
fonctionnement du service au contraire
même laïcité leur garantit l'égalité
devant le service public si le burqini
atteste en principe d'une appartenance à
une religion et ne porte pas pour autant
en lui-même atteinte au principe de
laïcité en effet le juge administratif
s'est déjà prononcé sur ce sujet il y en
a conclu que le port du burkini à la
plage n'est pas incompatible avec le
principe de laïcité sauf trouble à
l'ordre public le burqini n'est donc pas
un problème en soi mais il peut le
devenir en raison d'autres circonstances
comme le comportement de ceux qui les
portent ou d'autres troubles comme cela
a pu arriver à cisco en corse il ya
quelques années
seul en réalité une loi pourrait
interdire une tenue au sein des services
publics ou au sein même de l'espace
public ce qui est le cas avec la loi de
2004 à l'école où la loi dite sur le
voile intégral en réalité sauf si le
juge venait à modifier sa vision de la
mixité la seule faille de cette
délibération grenobloise semble résider
dans la procédure en effet le règlement
intérieur d'une piscine municipale
relève normalement mr et non pas du
conseil municipal est donc en droit il
appartient au maire et à lui seul de
prendre cette décision cela ne change
rien au fond mais cela pourrait bien
donner raison au préfet au moins sur la
procédure
allez c'est l'heure de sortir dans les
yvelines dans ce set week-end
[Musique]
bixente 1106 tebbane de retour en
plateau et on commence votre partie
loisirs bixente avec un invité c'est un
retour aux sources pour vous je ne peux
pas le cacher mon prénom en dit assez
long le pays basque cinq connaît une
région réputée pour son côté festif
c'est mais les plus gourmands sa
convivialité et plus besoin de faire 800
km pour aller découvrir cette culture
puisqu'elle vient directement à nous ce
week-end la troisième édition des fêtes
lysiane ça débute à saint germain en
lait dès ce soir pour en parler benoît
battistelli par visioconférence bonjour
bonjour monsieur batistyl vous êtes
adjoint à la culture de saint germain en
laye les fêtes luzienne donc comme je
disais début de ce soir au programme
démonstration de pelote basque lancement
de concours du gâteau basque et dachau
la bataille de confettis on rentre fort
dès ce soir dans l'ambiance des trois
prochains jours
écouté
beaucoup de l'historique ne serait qu'à
travers
et comme chaque année à saint germain
grande part toute sa vie comment il est
parti au personnel et 8h10 et variés qu
en 8es donc
une
défaite nous avons
et qui au lieu
début juin donc comme vous l'avez dit
aux fascinantes entraîneur mais voilà il
est le mariage de louis xiv qui s'est
déroulé à saint-jean-de-luz allier les
deux villes donc depuis c'est un nombre
comme on disait qui fait référence les
fêtes luzienne à la ville de
saint-jean-de-luz aux pays-bas ce
pourquoi organiser c'est fait donc le
but c'est vraiment perpétuer cette
tradition entre les deux communes en
fait si vous voulez
mon fai free qui permet de
l'autre
elles ont des similitudes sortie de
territoire et sont tournés vers ils ont
cru pour un effet d'obliger ces deux
créations de finale les jeunes assez
souvent hervé avait avec j'ai utilisé
les sympathiques
avec une vie peut entrer et donc au delà
des fêtes hier
ils nous permettent de connaître
ça commence les fêtes les haines débute
dès ce soir pour ceux qui ne peuvent pas
venir aux temps forts de ce soir demain
ceux ci une journée très chargée samedi
donc 21 mai à partir de 10h30 avec
pelote basque sur un fronton remise des
prix des concours et les bandes as
toute la ville et de diapason puisque ce
n'est pas que sur la place du marché
neuf beaucoup de restaurants aussi
autres commerces participent c'est la
volonté de mêler tous les saint
germanois à cette fête
en rouge et les couleurs de
nombreux
ont proposé des plats battent ou comme
tâche de vaud le gâteau basque
dizaines de pâtisseries et nourrir de st
et puis ne meurent pas de compte de
leurs actes les bandas ce 10 mai la
ville et puis tu réellement le soir les
deux soient francs 10 pas dire ce soit
il y a lancé deux parties et le fameux
taureau des fouets qui peine en faisant
donc voilà tant défaut balance et
compétitive aussi des bandas ce pour
bien animé tout le week-end merci
beaucoup benoît battistelli d'avoir été
avec nous donc je rappelle les fêtes
fusil m dès ce vendredi soir
j'en ai et tout le week-end des 21 et 22
mai petit mot de la fin je vois monsieur
battistelli vous êtes déjà aux couleurs
avec le petit foulard rouge voilà aux
couleurs de saint jean de luz
la météo promet du soleil à port
harcourt de 18h venez nombreux
merci beaucoup monsieur battistelli
d'avoir été avec nous merci
effectivement à votre invité si on peut
revoir la petite animation autour de ces
fêtes luzienne avec notamment le site
internet de la ville de saint germain en
laye qui s'affiche puisque la connexion
n'a pas été tout le temps bonne dans
cette interview on s'en excuse mais en
tout cas vous retrouver et bien sûr
toutes les informations sur le site
internet de la ville de
saint-germain-en-laye on continue avec
une autre idée de sortie des chutes est
plus proche de la nature oui pour les
journées de l'environnement qui arrive
prochainement plusieurs villes ont
organisé leur fête de la nature ce
week-end donc à carrières sous poissy
samedi qu en cours mais aussi plaisir
donc depuis le 18 mai jusqu'à dimanche
22 mai de nombreuses lieux de la ville
ans sont investis pour des ateliers
découverte des expositions en espérant
que le temps soit clément c'est la
deuxième édition reportage je suis à
vers luc maurin adjointe à
l'embellissement et à la promotion de la
nature à plaisir nous avons la fête de
la nature qui se déroule ce week-end sur
notre ville ce parc aujourd'hui qui est
magnifique qui dispose aussi d'un plan
d'eau accueillera de nombreuses
manifestations durant cette fête de la
nature
[Musique]
le plan d'eau et offre de nombreuses
possibilités
nous avons un autre plan d'eau bois de
la cram qui lui aussi accueillera
manifestation pour la découverte de la
peuple de l'eau nous avons choisi en
fait deux thèmes cette année un thème de
la nature nourricière et le thème de la
faune nocturne donc d'autant fort pour
ce pour ce week-end notamment la
plantation d'un verger dans le quartier
de la clique qui est un quartier très
urbanisées et nous accueillons une
association l'association les petits qui
piquent qui préserve et qui tend à
sensibiliser la préservation des
hérissons tous les lieux qui sont
aujourd'hui à plaisir qui met en valeur
cette cette nature seront mis à
l'honneur donc le parc du château avec
des découvertes grâce à un naturaliste
photographes amateurs
nous avons bien sûr aussi la découverte
des abeilles nous avons un apiculteur
sûr plaisir qui viendra animer des
ateliers
[Applaudissements]
mais
on pense souvent connaître la nature et
finalement il ya beaucoup d'aspects
qu'on découvre lorsqu'on s'y intéressent
vraiment les ateliers découverte
aujourd'hui permettent cette meilleure
connaissance donc j'invite tous les
plaisirs ans et les personnes aux
alentours à se référer au programme qui
est sur le site de la ville et à venir
découvrir dans le détail cette nature
autre rendez vous ce samedi bixente du
côté du marché de trappes pour une
découverte celle de l'association
conteneurs sans frontières à la base
c'était un projet scolaire et on le fait
par les élèves et professeurs du collège
gustave courbet attrape le but récolter
de l'argent et du matériel scolaire pour
l'envoyer au sénégal dans la région de
tambacounda plus d'informations avec le
responsable de l'association el hadji
drame
[Musique]
en présence frontières c'est une
association
qui est créé sous l'impulsion des
gazelles gustavo crevé on connaît
beaucoup de matériel scolaire que ça
soit informatiques sas wallin oublié ou
autre ou foulée terry scolaire donc du
coup pour l'envoyer dans les écoles
sénégalais et iv les établissements
[Musique]
on a prévu comme indication nous de
présenter comme entre le téléphone n'est
pas africaine on a organisé pour pouvoir
connecter 10 fois pour que nous
puissions envoyer un conteneur
à midi l'entretien une installation à
fait nous allons monter tout ce qu'on
avait fait comme intéresse depuis le
premier contenait jusqu'à actuellement
savait aussi que parler aussi comment
guérir les difficultés qu'auront un
compte aujourd'hui le souci des deux
côtés récente cinquième on parle de ça
et nous allons comment il allait faire
une exposition d'un goal to cookie qui
va trouver un bout
[Musique]
et pour terminer bixente quelques autres
agenda du week end oui puisque
contrairement à notre habitude on ne va
pas se projeter dans la semaine
prochaine mais bien rester à ce week-end
parce qu'on commence dès ce soir avec la
fête des voisins un rendez vous
convivial pour apprendre à connaître
ceux qui vivent parfois à seulement
quelques mètres de chez soi et que l'on
ne croise jamais ça nous est tous des
souvenirs machette par exemple quand
j'étais petit c'était un peu le le
moment où j'allais de rue en rue volet
des saucisses ou voisins a piqué
l'apéritif vous rêveriez vous avez des
petits souvenirs de fêtes des voisins et
des voisins des petits souvenirs ou et
des petites parties de foot avec les
enfants des autres voisins et ça ça
permet de de nouer des liens de nouer
des amitiés montré en être les adultes
aussi c'est vraiment voilà une soirée
pour ouvrir la porte à ses voisins
d'ailleurs la transition est toute
trouvée grégory puisqu'à présent nous
allons parler aussi de portes ouvertes
ce week-end samedi et dimanche 63
centres spa de france organisent leur
porte verte adoption dans le département
les centres de plaisir orgeval et et
meurent et participeront à l'opération
l'idée c'est d'aller à la rencontre de
nos merveilleux compagnon canin et félin
ou autres les nouveaux animaux de
compagnie on rappelle que la période
estivale est une période plus forte
propice à l'abandon il faut donc libérer
un maximum de place pour entamer au
mieux l'été portes ouvertes donc samedi
dimanche dans les centres de plaisir
orgeval et et murray on termine bixente
par un autre plaisir tout à l'heure vous
nous avez parlé des fêtes luzienne l'on
parle de sport aussi qui vous
intéressent tous directement avec un
rendez vous ô combien important pour le
rugby club de versailles a mis dimanche
le rcv joue son match de l'année à la
maison un 16e de finale retour de
fédérale 3 face à servian boujan après
un match aller perdu la semaine dernière
26 10 les versaillais ont plus que
jamais besoin du soutien de leur public
match à 15 heures dimanche au stade paul
fontaine à versailles en cas de remontée
à dalé versailles et continueront leur
parcours dans ce championnat de france
de fédérale 3 donc ils accèderont aux
huitièmes de finale mais surtout ils
valideront leur montée dans la division
supérieure la fédérale 2 en cas de
défaite rien n'est perdu pour la monter
un autre match de barrage pour accéder à
la division de fédérale 2 se jouera en
aller retour fin mai début juin environ
un mille personnes sont attendues au
stade l'entrée sera bien entendu
gratuite le merci bixente on se retrouve
bien sûr dès la semaine prochaine pour
de nouvelles idées de sorties dans le
sahtu ce week-end
et on va refermer cette émission au
festival de cannes la grande fête du
cinéma est au programme jusqu'au 28 mai
radio sensations à partenariat avec tv
78 nous fait vivre l'événement de
l'intérieur en allant à la rencontre des
producteurs réalisateurs et acteurs de
notre région focus aujourd'hui sur le
poids que représente le cinéma sur
l'emploi dans la région ile de france le
centre national de la cinématographie a
dévoilé les nouveaux chiffres du secteur
en termes d'emploi l'occasion de faire
un point après la pandémie la région ile
de france concentre 55 % des activités
de la filière cinéma loin devant les
régions sud provence alpes côte d'azur
et auvergne rhône-alpes toutes les 2 à
7% alors comment est ce qu'on explique
cette prédominance de notre région les
explications avec rémy berg directeur de
films paris région je pense que la
région de france et la première
collectivité territoriale en france en
termes de faune locale en termes de
soutien au cinéma avec donc ce budget de
25 millions d'euros pour le cinéma et
donc ça a concentré depuis très très
longtemps les professionnels en
ile-de-france donc plus de cent
cinquante mille personnes dans la région
de france travaillent dans la filière
image chaque année la région ile de
france soutient 150 films que leur
demande t-elle en échange on écoute rémy
bergues pour pouvoir bénéficier d'une
aide du fonds de soutien de la région
d'une aide à l'écriture ou d'une aide
après réalisation il faut que plus de la
moitié du tournage soient réalisés en
ile de france et nous avons évidemment
plus de 2500 lieux de tournage qui sont
référencés dans toute l'île de france au
sein de films par les régions la
commission du film d'île de france et en
ile de france certains lieux sont
privilégiés pour le tournage me caler la
place des yvelines paris intra muros
évidemment la première destination
interne le tournage en termes de
territoire francilien la
seine-saint-denis est un département
important qui accueille de plus en plus
de productions les yvelines oui si vous
avez évidemment le château de versailles
mais vous avez d'autres lieux qui
accueillent beaucoup de tournages dans
les abîmes donc 300 lieu dans notre base
les corps qui sont exigées et puis en
essonne il est aussi des territoires
comme les ricoh couronne qui sont en
train de se développer énormément dans
l'accueil de tournages
voyez par harry est de plus en plus
comment dire complet en terme de
tournage et les départements de la
petite couronne est de plus en plus de
la grande couronne sont en train
d'absorber toute cette demande française
et internationale pour tourner des
offres en ile de france parmi les films
soutenus à découvrir on retrouve le
consentement de vanessa fils autorise
lots qui t'a de jean pierre et luc
dardenne ou encore la bête de bertrand
bonello et suite des aventures cannoises
de radio sensations et de tv soixante
dix huit la semaine prochaine justement
sur tv 78 voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission retour de l'information locale
dès lundi soir avec le journal de la
rédaction à 18h sur notre antenne et
d'ici là passez un excellent week-end
sur tv 78
[Musique]